[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Ну мрія — стати пілотом.
Ви можете собі уявити, щоб в державному великому сенсі
[Буковина
Чернівці]
стати цивільним пілотом, чи пілотом військовим —
не вдалося, але ж мрія живе!
Якщо людина не має якоїсь мрії,
вона потихеньку чахне.
[Леонід Ковальчук
Авіатор]
Щоб не зачахнути, потрохи-потрохи, і дійшло до такого стану.
Ноги на педалі, вліво-вправо,
ручка керування.
Ось так погляд, і вперед.
Ось так буде оглядатися земля.
На Хмельниччині,
шестирічним пацаном,
з батьком влітку йшли.
Батько — агроном.
І тут раптом з неба Ан-2
сідає на майданчик,
заправляється хімікатами.
Все, іскра Божа попала в голову.
З цього все і почалося.
Вся авіація у Радянському Союзі
належала військовим.
Мені навіть розповідали, що
у Банилові-Підгірному людина робила літак,
і під'їхали «співробітники»,
там уже КамАЗ стояв з краном...
Не питаючи нічого, витягнули
той його майбутній літак з гаража,
завантажили, ще пішли,
позабирали креслення і поїхали.
«Будеш ще щось робити — будеш мати проблеми», — ось і все, що вони сказали.
У цілому світі саморобні літаки мають напис на фюзеляжі «Експерементал».
І по цілому світі літають.
Тобто ти виконуєш всі правила
і береш відповідальність на себе.
Перший політ буде тільки самостійно, бо  літак експериментальний.
Піддавати ризику інших людей
я не маю права.
Це — «Де Гевілленд 60» називається.
Перший у світі, розроблений в Англії легендарним конструктором Джеффрі де Гевіллендом.
Спеціальний літак для приватного використання.
Я вирішив у 2003-му році розпочати здійснення цього проекту в Україні.
І от, всього 50 метрів потрібно для того, щоб розпочати політ.
І десь метрів 100 — щоб приземлитися.
Тобто будь-який шматок дороги, поля — може використовуватися у якості аеродрому.
На цьому літаку по світу політати.
Повторити політ Емі Джонсон.
З Англії у Австралію, скажімо, через Україну.
Спробувати таке здійснити.
Подивимось. Мрія така є, але як воно буде — хтозна.
Планую, що з однією заправкою, з цим дизелем, приблизно 1300 км можна пролетіти.
При використанні приблизно семи літрів дизельного пального на годину.
Паливний бак очікується — 70 літрів.
Чернівці-Суми, спробуємо здійснити ткий переліт.
1000 км виходить.
Літак цілком майже дерев'яний.
Застосовується наша карпатська сосна.
Переклей.
Я є діючим пластуном-скаутом, сеньйором.
Щороку навчаю дітей, даю практичні знання, авіаційні навички.
У нас є курінь, називається «Чота Крилатих»
у Івано-Франківській області,
Богородчанський район, село Луквиця.
Туди я приїджаю щороку, вчу людей.
Наступним після цього літака
пранується планер, навчальний.
Щоб вчити юнаків і дівчат авіаційній справі.
— Привіт!
— Де тут начальство?
— Є, десь там.
— Добрий день. Є директор?
— Не знаю, схоже, немає.
Тут гурток повітряних зміїв, моделювання і конструювання транспортних засобів.
Цього року є 15 новачків.
От такі літачки прості, з паперу,
з рейок.
Невеличка рогатка береться і запускається.
Це називається «слінг шутер».
І воно злітає метрів на 15-20 і планує.
«Mississippi Western River».
А ось це — перший у світі рейсовий автобус.
Ця модель літає:
всередину дві гумки вставляються,
гвинт крутиться —
вона може підлетіти і трошки полетіти.
Вона зроблена з будівельного
пінопласту синього кольору
і мисочки для м'яса, знаєте, є такі мисочки жорсткі.
Крила з такого матеріалу і зроблені.
Емі Джонсон пролетіла
800 миль за компасом.
Останнім її пунктом був Дарвін, Австралія.
Після островів, Малайзію, Філіппіни вона облетіла.
Отаке вона над морем здійснила.
Я так подумав:
«Дівчина у 23 роки змогла полетіти,
а я — досвідчений дядько, 58 років,
чому б мені не спробувати це здійснити».
«I wanna fly across the world».
«I have a dream».
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Олег Сологуб, Михайло Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Анна Воробйова]
[Музика
Zenberry]
[Субтитрувальниця
Іра Жукевич]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]